- Aujourd'hui, j'annonce que
le gouvernement a a a a a a a al
un montant de 250 millionsdeded.
- Québec ouvre les valves.
45 millions de dollars chaque
pour l'embauche de policiers.
5 millions pour l'embauche
d'intervenants socfifififin
d'alléger les interventions
des policiers.
de la Sécurité publique, Québec
- J'ai toujours dit : s'il faut
en faire plus, on va en faire
plus. Le gouvernement
sera au rendez-vous.
égalisera le nombre
d'hehehehes par Québec.
L'objectif : avoir 450 nouveaux
policiers dans les rues
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Montréal ne sera pas
le terrain de jeu des criminels.
- Laaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaia,
l'accusant de fermer les yeux
sur la rétention des policiers
à Montréal. Aujourd'hui :
Certains se questionnent jejej,
sans compter que les départs
à laiaiaiaite pourraient
Certains se questionnent sur
la faisabilité de ces objectifs,
sans compter que les départs
être nombreux dans
les preseseses années.
ANDRÉ GÉLINAS, sergent-détective
à la retraite, SPVM
monde à trouver pour justement
arriver à un + 450, là.
Est-ce que, en amont,
le systeme scolaire,
incluanticicicicicicicicicicici?
Est-ce qu'il va y avoir
l'
- D'autres voudraiiriririr
plus de sommes investies
directement pour aider à réduire
PIERRESON VAVAL,
intervenant communautaire
- Non, on veut que des sommes
soient engagées pour
qu'on puisse rejoindrenenenenenr
les jeunes qui ont
ssssssssiers criminels,
des jeunes qui... sortent
de prison, des jeunes qui ont
- Une entente a aussi été
conclue avec lououououououououox
policiers devraient graduer
de l'École d'ici mars 2023 et
rejoindre les rangs du SPVM.
En moins d'un llllllllllllllllli
ont été investis par Québec
pour lutter contre
la violence par arme à feu.
Radio-Canada, Montréal.